Buenas tardes la fiscalía Afirma tener
pruebas que sostiene acusan al
expresidente Pedro Pablo kuczynski de
haber lavado doce millones de dólares en
la empresa brasileña odebrecht a través
de asesorías disfrazadas para la
construcción de obras de infraestructura
esto a su vez ha sido
refutado por la defensa del expresidente
la fiscalía está pidiendo 35 años de
prisión para el ex mandatario y también
para tres personas de este entorno así
como cuatro compañías privadas el
Ministerio Público también le está
solicitando a la justicia peruana que
amplíe por tres meses más el pedido de
impedimento de salida del país contra
kuczynski porque señala que debe ser
retenido para Que responda por estos
hechos diversos allegados al ex
mandatario señalan que hasta el momento
no se ha aprobado nada y que el expr
padece de un mal cardíaco ya ha estado
en prisión y luego ha estado bajo el
régimen de arresto domiciliario y que ya
es hora de que la justicia se ponga a
trabajar y que si el expresidente es
inocente que lo liberen de todo tipo de
proceso pero la fiscalía está señalando
que sí hay pruebas y que va a demostrar
en el proceso judicial bueno kuczynski
tiene 84 años y están pidiendo 35 años
de cárcel Cómo ha reaccionado el
expresidente
justamente el ex mandatario kuczynski ha
dado a conocer que él se siente
tranquilo señalado que es inocente y que
demostrará que no ha cometido ningún
delito así lo ha dado a conocer su
abogado Julio midolo quien ha
manifestado hasta el momento el
Ministerio Público no ha formalizado a
la defensa técnica de kuczynski este
pedido de 35 años de y también ha
manifestado que hasta el momento el
Ministerio Público no ha mostrado
evidencias que acusen formalmente al
expresidente cuchinski de haber cometido
algún delito de lavado de activos en la
manifestado que va a demostrar a través
de este proceso que se le viene
siguiendo que no hay ningún tipo de
tificación para que pueda ser procesado
y señala a todas luces Hay algún tipo de
reacción contraria al ex mandatario lo
cierto según algunos analistas es que el
expresidente kuczynski está ahorita
preocupado por la información que pueda
brindar el expresidente Alejandro Toledo
quien ayer ha sido interrogado por la
fiscalía de este país y se teme que él
pueda por tener algún beneficio ante la
justicia peruana delatar o inculpar a
otras personas que hayan colaborado en
su gobierno que fue del 2001 al 2006
cuando kuczynski precisamente fue
ministro de estado en el gobierno de
Alejandro Toledo